hello everyone and welcome to a game uh
from round six of the norway chess 2022
a game that is very important for the
tournament standings it's magnus carlsen
versus shakhtar mamidyarov of course you
know who both of them are so no need for
any additional introduction it's uh
really uh
a wild game so you guys will enjoy it
but before we check it out a very quick
announcement that um well i would like
to congratulate uh shashank matufika
from hungary on successfully finishing
medical
school and officially becoming a doctor
marcel and i are both very proud of you
so that being said let's enjoy some
chess and
see what this is all about
magnus opens with knight to f3 and it's
very scary uh when you face the ready
opening not for these um 2800 players
but you know for everyone else when you
when you see the red ear like okay i i
know i have no idea what's happening
here uh so here we have d5 mommy there
uh strikes in the center that's the kind
of the idea behind that you say i'm not
going to develop my pawns i'm going to
control the center with my pieces and
black says all right you don't want to
put your pawns in the center i'm going
to do exactly that so g3 we have g6 and
now the shorter g2 yeah we are
controlling the center with the pieces
like we said bishop to g7 and now uh
pawn to d4 we have knights to f6 uh and
now both players castle so castles
castles and we transpose into the king's
indian attack the double fiance
variation uh we have c4 uh
striking against the center c6 knight to
c3 and d captures on c4 so this is all
very standard stuff this is the top um
line uh recommended by the engine uh e4
grabbing the center now that mamadarav
captured on c4 and now bishop to g4
pinning the knight with h3 saying okay
uh you played bishop to g4 now you have
to capture on f3 bishop captures and we
have to capture with the bishop if we
capture with the queen we lose the d4
pawn so bishop captures uh and now ponte
e5 this is what um mamidara finds and it
seems like a pawn sacrifice but uh not
really because after pawn captures uh
knight after d7 and now we're gonna win
back the pawn and uh
will have a very very nice development
but magnus plays e6 and this is of
course um a prepared move it was played
by uh not just one of his uh seconds by
but by both of them was played by jordan
van forest and also uh by daniel dubov
uh and the noob of the uh double won
again with e6 van forest draw game uh
but um obviously they they have it ready
so here f captures an e6 and now bishop
to e3 magnus gives back the pawn this
way and ruins the moment of the king
side a little bit and also creates an
isolated e pawn which will which we can
attack later on so usually when your
opponent gives you a pawn at uh you know
gain some rapid development or to gain
some sort of an advantage if you can
choose a way in which you can give give
back that pawn uh you have to do it in a
way that at least uh cost your opponent
something as well uh and here knight to
e5 is the move that was played in both
of the games that um
uh fun forest and do both played but
here we have queen to e7 by mom and yarf
and it is not as of move 13 that we have
a completely new game uh so we have
russia back to g2 by magnus and now
knight to a6 we have queen to e2
connecting the rooks developing the
queen and going after the c4 pawn and
now knight to be forcing okay you can
capture on c4 i'm gonna play knight to c
to attack your bishop and the rook but
it's not a problem that's exactly what
magnus wants queen captures on c4 knight
to c2 and now not allowing any capturing
of rook or bishop there's the very nice
knight to d5 now opening up a discovery
here and a discovery here and again i
really hope none of you are considering
knight captures on e3 and then we're
going to capture the queen you know just
as well because if you capture this
comes with check and you've just
blundered the game so after knight to d5
c captures on d5 attacking the queen and
queen captures on c2 now mommy daryl of
course brings the rook into the game
with tempo uh but not just yet first he
advances this pawn to d4 challenges the
bishop and after bishop to d2 now rook
ate the c8 again which tempo the queen
is attacked queen to b3 putting pressure
on b7 and now knight to c5 defending and
attacking on b3 so queen a3 pinning the
knight the queen on e7 is undefended and
the queen to d7 unpinning uh so here you
can see that uh
okay momidarov does have a weak e6 pawn
but he also has a pass pawn on d4 so you
gain something you lose something and
it's a it's a very equalished position
the problem is magnus had this analyzed
at home and he is spending very little
time and money is burning a lot of time
uh trying to uh find the right ideas
here rook eight to c1 uh putting
pressure on the knight and b6 defending
the knight also the queen now guards the
a7 pawn
so here how do you continue with white
again a beautiful positional idea e5 by
magnus just giving up a pawn to open up
the bishop's diagonal
and
open up lines of attack towards that e6
pawn so here uh do you capture or not
you could also try something like queen
a4 or for a queen trade first but
mamidarov accepts the challenge bishop
captures an e5
now uh sorry not rook if the d1 rook
after e1 attacks the bishop and we are
going to put pressure on that e6 pawn so
here bishop back to g7 and pawn to b for
now kicking away the knight and allowing
the queen to gain access to the to the
b3 square so knight to a4 and now rook
captures on c8 rook captures on c8 and
of course queen to b3 we want to play a3
at some point either way and of course
now we are attacking the e6 pawn and you
could defend it but i think mamadarov
was no longer interested in a draw here
he said all right you sacrificed the
pawn it's not a very good sacrifice i'm
going to win this i have a pass deep on
it's nicely protected
and
he played knight the c3 if he wanted he
could play rook to e8 and uh well it's
not much but let's say rook captures on
e6 rook captures bishop d5 now uh we can
play king to f7 and now we can just
trade captures captures the queen no
longer defends the knight so queen
captures on a4 we get this position
where it's equal material and uh well
it's uh it's not much but um you can
play it so that's why i think momidaro
was more interested in actually winning
this game than going for some sort of a
drawn line so he played knight to c3 he
gives up the e6 pawn right away we have
rook captures on e6 now threatening all
sorts of nasty discoveries if the rook
moves so king the h8 and now king the h2
getting the king to a bit of a safer
square before uh continuing uh uh at uh
you know find ideas uh rook to e8
offering a rook trait and magnus trades
with captures captures and now queen to
c4
here we have h6 and now pawn to a3 and
here a5 momidarov just wants to trade
off the pawns on the queen side b
captures b captures and now uh we have
bishop to f1 now the bishop is coming to
d3 and will put pressure on this uh
diagonal so it's a very very tricky
position uh
magnus with the bishop pair but
mamadirov does have this very tricky
knight and you know if the knight
sometime somehow lands on f3 with the
black queen properly positioned
could be very very annoying so here we
have queen to f8 going after the f2 pawn
magnus defense king to g2 we have knight
to e for now putting pressure on the
bishop and bishop to e1 so carlson's
bishop pair is forced
into sort of passivity but
they will come alive it's not a
permanent thing hopefully now the real
question is is uh can mamidarov capture
on a3 if he can capture an a3 then he
will have the past deep on end of the
past a pawn but it might come
at a price of of being attacked because
carlson's king is uh uh much safer than
mamidarov's king and he look at these
pawns already on the sixth rank and
carlson spawns uh nicely nicely uh
placed uh so yeah okay the f2 pawn is a
little bit weak but the bishop on e1
even though awkwardly placed uh defends
the f2 pawn very nicely so here
mamidarov accepts the challenge and this
is the only good move for black so here
queen captures on a3 and now bishop to
d3 attacking the knight and if the
knight moves we can also grab the pawn
on g6 and now the thing is if you offer
a queen trade with queen to c5 of course
we want to trade we're gonna play queen
to queen to a4 let's say
and now when black moves the knight then
we are going to win the a5 pawn so
that's how we're going to do it so
instead we have knight to d6 uh going
after
magnus's queen on c4 and now queen to a6
we have knight to f5 now and ponte h4 uh
there's no rush we can always capture
the pawn here uh and now comes ponta h5
and this is uh
a move you have to play if you play
something like a4 if you want to protect
the pawn then h5 really undermines
black's black's position and you you
can't really
hope to survive this of course if you
capture you just blunder a knight and it
is just a terrible position so instead
after h4 h5 is played preventing this
and only now magnus plays bishop
captures on a5 with king to h7 the king
has to be uh
safe in order to
avoid checks and allow black to maybe
start pushing that pawn but for the
moment it is blockaded by the bishop on
d3 so queen b5 now the dark square
bishop will also
get into the attack we have queen all
the way back to f8 and now queen to d5 a
very nice centralizing move
when a position is unclear like this and
this is quite an unclear position uh
even if you if you're playing a blitz
game even if you have a few seconds on
the clock maybe you have an increment of
a few seconds uh centralizing your queen
will always uh uh cause problems for
your opponent because he doesn't know if
there's something that you've just
planned or you you've just increased
activity of your queen so remember that
for future use uh here queen to d6
offering a queen trade and magnus goes
back queen to f3
now bishop captures an f3 might also be
an idea so here we have queen to e5
defending the knight now the real trick
here in the position and of course the
one madera would see if he had a bit
more time on the clock uh was queen to
a3 that's the real trick going after the
bishop and once you move the bishop and
it doesn't matter where you move the
bishop and now we play knight to e3
check and the queen no longer defends
the bishop on uh d3 that's the that's
the good stuff here so here after f
captures we're going to play queen
captures here and after he captures on
d4 just queen to c to check for example
king to h3 and now we continue playing
this uh but with the white king so
so wide open with its defenses busted uh
well it will be a fairly easy draw for
black but okay uh queen to e5 and now we
have bishop to d8 by magnus
queen to e6 now and the queen to b7 and
now again the mamidorov is very low on
time look at the bishop pair slicing all
over the place queen controlling the
seventh rank it is not easy finding
moves for black here so knight the d6
going after the queen queen to c6
spinning the knight uh and now momidaro
has to make a move the problem is he has
uh 30 seconds on the clock and i think
he actually made this move uh next move
with like uh
maybe even i'm not going to say a second
but maybe three seconds on the clock uh
he played queen to b3 and now the what
you have to play here to survive is
something like bishop to f6 or bishop to
e5 you just offer a bishop trade if
magnus moves the bishop then you keep
the bishop on e5 and you say okay you
you figure out what to play here the
problem is mamitara played
queen to b3 he went for the bishop on d3
and he missed one a very very
uh tricky idea for magnus so feel free
to pause the video and win the game for
magnus while i give you a couple of
seconds and you have to find a few moves
not just one move so have at it
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh spotting this
uh not just uh move that wins upon but
also that gives you a completely winning
position and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show uh it is again
our good friend the light square bishop
bishop captures on g6 with check uh and
now okay what do you play king captures
on g6 there really isn't a better move
and now queen captures on d6 so now we
were the the bishop was hanging either
way so if we just captured momodaro with
capture on d3 this way we grab a pawn
and then capture on d6 and this is uh
maybe
even saw this but he didn't think that
the position is winning maybe he thought
that he can hold it but after king to h7
there is the only winning move and the
magnus plays at queen to d7 now uh you
can't start pushing your pawn if you
start pushing your pawn bishop f6 and
that's it how are you defending
checkmate only ways to bring the queen
back and now we just trade everything
captures captures captures captures king
of three we we win the pawn and it's
three against one of course in a
completely winning end game for white so
after queen 37 king the g6 my mom and
daughter of now not allowing the pinning
of the bishop and the queen the c6 with
check now king f7 we have queen to c5
and now when you play we have queen to
b7 again uh if you play something like
pawn to d3 then queen captures and h5
comes with check and it's uh well not
not a move you you can afford to make uh
so here uh after this queen the c5 queen
to b7 was played uh now delivering check
to the white king f3 and now king the e8
attacking the bishop here with the king
bishop the c7 and the now comes queen to
b2 with check we have king to h3 and now
carlson's king is completely safe here
and there is not all that much you can
do uh so here d3 we have to try this
it's uh the pushing of the pass pawn
it's the only counter play mommy has but
now queen captures an h5 we are now up
two pawns as white and uh we can uh be
sure that this is winning if this pawn
does not promote so here we have king to
d7 the black king is in check we have
queen to f7 with czech king to c6 but he
was also in this position after playing
king to c6 that mahmoud resigned to the
game
as there is nothing more to be done here
to give you an example of how the game
might continue just queen to c4 check
and once the king moves of course now
saying that you can't capture because
the bishop hangs we're just going to
play bishop to f4 and after d2 there's
uh now the very simple matter of just uh
giving a few checks and connecting the
queen with the pawn on d2 because the
bishop is attacking the pawn let's say
queen to the c7 check doesn't matter
where you go because both of these
checks connect with the pawn and let's
say king a6 we're gonna play queen to d6
check king a7 and now just gobble up the
pawn and with three extra pawns of
course this is now completely winning uh
any one of you watching this would
easily win this against uh
of or magnus i have i have no doubts
about that
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it after king to c6 and
mamadou resigns and the magnus gets
another victory in the classical
uh classical section which means uh he
overtakes viswanathan anand as the
leader of the tournament as anand did
win his match against anish giri but he
did not win the classical he won the
armageddon game or rather he had the
black pieces the game was drawn and then
he was of course the winner of the
armageddon
so magnus now takes the lead in the
tournament ahead of vishwanathan anand
and we're going to discuss the standings
after we check out um a few more games
maybe from round six uh for those of you
who are interested magnus sort of
started his uh again started his
unbeaten classical streak he he has been
unbeaten for 62 classical games uh
winning 29 of them and drawing 33. uh so
in case you guys are wondering and he is
uh
on his uh well path the
trying to reach that unreachable uh you
know peak of 2900 classical elo uh which
is just unimaginable here uh you guys
can see uh these are the the world top
20. you can see magnus 2870 currently uh
he is on a plus 6.4 here in norway as he
is doing very well in classical only
ding above 2800 with 2806 you can see
the difference between magnus and ding
is 64 points that's
that's crazy and then you have um
breaks into the top ten he is also on
plus 11 here in norway as he is playing
incredible classical chess
anisha on 10th and the the list goes on
but uh just uh to give you an idea of
how difficult it is to reach that it's
only 30 more points to 2900 but you you
cannot afford to lose a game because
it'll just you know ruin the entire
tournament for you uh so yeah once again
i hope you guys enjoyed it i would like
to thank richard knapp raymond young
sarah simmons evalia and lego and david
kimura for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event uh until it finishes
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day